you want to tell us a story about how
you landed the Liu then I hope no one
from work listen to this um why does no
one know no no is it's just they fed up
hearing
it no it's um I just got bored of doing
the same sort of BD approaches right
they were growing their first data team
and I remember seeing incredible caliber
candidate joined them as their Chief
that's I thought you're not hiring
someone of that caliber if you're not
going to go and expand a team and um
their office was a f minute walk from
ours so after Relentless approaches
being rejected and just turned down and
just radio silence I am myself to get a
box of crispy creams took our client
brochure with us I think the the tagline
I put on the note was um you've been
delivering to me for the last few months
I'd love to deliver some Candace see you
lo and behold it became a good client
for us so it did pay off